My name is Adnan and I've been learning Mandarin inside school.
I wanna be into banking 'cause it's lots of money.
Maybe I can get lots of deals by talking to Chinese people.
We're not learning something that we used to...
...and it's not like anything we've ever done before.
We're just used to doing English and maths,...
...but now we're gonna learn a completely new language.
It's actually really unique.
It's really interesting and it's fun to do.
You become more confident as a person being able to communicate with others.
I think Spanish is really useful because 40 plus countries speak Spanish.
So, I think business-wise it's gonna be helpful in the future.
Maths and English, it's more like, write on your books and look at the board...
...but here, we get to interact.
I've been teaching my parents.